so far we've been able to define the
determinant for a two-by-two matrix this
is our definition right here ad minus BC
and then we were able to broaden that a
bit by creating a definition for the
determinant of a 3x3 matrix and we did
that right here we did that right here
where we essentially said the
determinant is equal to each of these
terms you could call these maybe the
coefficient terms times the determinant
of the matrix you can kind of view it as
the sub matrix produce when you get rid
of each of these guys column and row so
when you got rid of this guy this guy's
column and row you're left with this
matrix so we said this guy times the
determinant of this and then we kept
switching signs minus this guy times the
determinant if you remove his column in
his row so it was left with these terms
right there to get that determinant then
finally you switch signs again so Plus
this guy times the determinant of the
2x2 matrix if you get rid of this row
and this column so it's this thing right
here which was this matrix now let's see
if we can extend this to a general n by
n matrix so let's write out our and by n
matrix right over here do it in blue so
let's say I have some matrix a that is
an N by n matrix so it's going to look
like it's going to look like this this
would be a 1 1 at B a 1 2 and we go all
the way to you're going to have n
columns a 1n and when you go down this
is going to be your second row a21 it's
going to go all the way down to a + 1
because you have n rows as well and then
if you go down the diagonal all the way
this right here would be a + n so there
is my n by n matrix now before I define
how to find the determinant of this let
me make another definition let me define
so this is my matrix a let me define let
me define a sub matrix a I J to be equal
to the this is n by n right so this is
going to be an N minus 1 by n minus 1
matrix so this is 7 by 7 the sub matrix
is going to be
six by six one less in each of in each
direction so this is going to be the n
minus 1 by n minus 1 matrix matrix you
get you get you get if you if you
essentially ignore if you if you ignore
or if you take away maybe I should say
take away let's say ignore I like the
word ignore if you ignore the I throw
the I throw this right here is the
road.the I throw and and the jth column
column of a so for example let's go back
to our 3x3 right here this thing could
be denoted based on that definition I'd
we could have called this this was a 1 1
this term right here we could denote the
matrix when you get rid of the first
column in the first row or the first or
the first column we could call this
thing right here we could call that big
matrix a11 so this was big matrix a11
this is big matrix a 2 1 or actually
this matrix was called C so this would
be C 1 1 this would right there c 1 1 we
could call this 1 this would be matrix c
c1 2 c1 2 why is that because if you get
rid of the first row if you get rid of
the first row let me get rid of the
first row right the first term is your
row you get rid of the first row and the
second column this is the matrix that's
left over 2 3 4 1 so this is this guy
and this guy 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 so this is
the sub matrix C because this is the big
matrix C but this one is C 1 2 I know
it's a little bit messy there C 1 2 so
that's all we mean by the sub matrix
very similar to what we did in the 3x3
case you essentially get rid of so if
you want to if you want to find out this
guy's sub matrix you would call that a 1
1 and you would literally cross out the
first row and the
first column and everything left over
here would be that sub-matrix
now with that out of the way we can
create a definition and it might seem a
little circular to you at first
and on some level it is we're going to
define the determinant of a to be equal
to to be equal this is interesting it's
actually a recursive definition I'll
talk about that in a second it's equal
to we start with a plus it's equal to
a11 times the sub matrix when you were
if you remove this guy's row and column
so that by definition is just a big
capital a one one's determinant so
that's exactly what we did let me write
that a little bit neater so time's the
determinant of the sub of its sub matrix
so the determinant of a 1 1 so you take
a 1 1 you get rid of its column it's row
or its row and it's column and you
everything else you find the determinant
of that actually let me write it in
terms of let me write it this way a 1 1
times the determinant of the sub-matrix
a 1 1 and then we switch sides we're
going to go along this row we're just
going to go along this row and then you
do minus a 1 2 times the determinant of
its sub-matrix which we'll just call a
1/2 we would get rid of this row and
this column and everything left would be
it's this matrix a 1 2 we want to find
its determinant and then we'll take the
next guy over here would be a 1 3 so we
switch signs with - now you go + so a 1
3 times the determinant of its
sub-matrix so these are if this is you
know this is n by n these are each
you're going to be n minus 1 by n minus
1 so the determinant of a 1 3 and you're
just going to keep doing that keep
switching signs so it's going to be
minus and then a plus and you keep going
all the way and then I don't know it
depends on whether a n whether we're
dealing with an odd number or an even
number if we're dealing with an even
number this is going to be a minus sign
if it's an odd number it's going to be a
plus sign but you get the idea see there
going to be a plus or minus not just if
it's if it's odd this is going to be a
plus if it's a if it's an even N or it's
going to be a minus
all the way to a1 n the nth column times
its sub-matrix a1 n where that sub
matrix get rid of the first row and the
nth column and it's going to be
everything that's left in between and
you immediately might say Sal what kind
of a definition is this you've defined
and determinant for arbitrary n by n
matrix in terms of another definition of
a determinant how does this work and the
reason why this works is because every
the determinant that you use in the
definition our determinant of a smaller
matrix so this is a determinant of an N
minus 1 by n minus 1 matrix now you're
saying hey Sal that you know that still
doesn't make any sense because we don't
know how to find the determinant of an n
minus 1 by n minus 1 matrix
well you apply this definition again and
then it's going to be in terms of n
minus 2 times n or n minus 2 by n minus
2 matrices you like how do you do that
well you keep doing it and you're going
to get all the way down to a 2 by 2
matrix you're going to get all the way
down to a 2 by 2 matrix and that one we
defined well we define the determinant
of a 2 by 2 matrix not in terms of a
determinant we just defined it in terms
of a times we defined it as let me write
it up here
it was a times D minus B times C and you
can see I mean we could just go down to
the 3 by 3 but the 2 by 2 is really the
most fundamental definition and you
could see that the definition of a 3 by
3 determinant is essentially it's a
special case of the general case for an
N by n we take this guy and we multiply
him times the determinant of his sub
matrix right there then we take this guy
when we switch signs we have a minus and
we multiply him times the determinant of
his sub matrix which is that right there
and you have then you do a plus you
switch signs and then you took multiply
this guy times the determinant of his
sub matrix which is that right there so
this is a general case of what I just
defined but we know it's never that
satisfying to deal in the abstract or
the generalities we want to do a
specific case and actually before I do
that let me just introduce the term to
you this is called a recursive formula
recursive and if you become a computer
science major you will see this a lot
but a recursive function or recursive
formula that is defined in terms of
itself but the things that you use in
the definition use a slightly simpler
version of it and
you keep going through you keep
recursing through it you get simpler and
simpler versions of it until you get to
some type of base case in this case our
base case is the case of a 2x2 matrix
you keep doing this and eventually
you'll get to a determinant of a 2 by 2
matrix and we know how to find those so
this is a recursive definition recursive
definition but let's actually apply it
because I think that's what actually
makes things concrete so let's take
let's take a this is going to take be
computationally intensive but I think if
we focus we can get there so I'm gonna
have a four by four matrix one two three
four one throw some zeros in there to
make the computation a little bit
simpler zero one two three and then two
three zero zero so let's figure out this
determinant let's figure out this
determinant right there this is the
determinant of the matrix if I put some
brackets there that would've been the
matrix but this is must find the
determinant of this matrix so this is
going to be equal to by our definition
it's going to be equal to 1 times the
determinant of this matrix right here if
you get rid of this row and this column
so it's going to be 1 times the
determinant of 0 2 0 1 2 3 3 0 0 that's
just this guy right here this matrix
right there then I'm going to have a 2
if I'm going to switch sign so it's
minus 2 minus 2 times the determinant if
I get rid of that row and this column so
it's 1 2 0 I'm ignoring the 0 because
they're in the same column as the 2 1 2
0 so 1 2 0 0 2 3 0 2 3 and then 2 0 0 2
0 0 and then I switch signs again it was
a minus so now I go back to plus I do
that guy so plus 3 times the determinant
of his sub matrix get rid of that row
get rid of that column I get a 1 0 0 1 0
0 I get a 0 1 3 right 0 1 3 0 1 3 I
skipped this
every time then I get a two three zero I
get a two three zero just like that
we're almost done one more in this
column let me switch to another color
and I could have used the blue in this
yet so then I'm going to do a minus four
remember it's plus minus plus minus four
times the determinant of its sub-matrix
that's going to be that right there so
it's 1 0 2 0 1 2 2 3 0 just like that
and now we're down to the 3 by 3 case we
could use the definition of the 3 by 3
but we could just keep applying this
recursive definition we could keep
applying this recursive definition here
so this is going to be equal to this is
going to be equal to let me write it
here so 1 times
what's this determinant this determine
is going to be 0 0 times the determinant
of that sub matrix 2 3 0 0 2 3 0 0 that
was this one right here and then we have
minus 2 minus this 2 where I remember we
switch signs plus minus plus so minus 2
times its sub-matrix so it's 1 3 3 0 1 3
3 0 and then finally plus 0 plus 0 times
its sub-matrix which is this thing right
here 1 2 3 0 1 2 3 0 just like that and
then we have this next guy right here as
you can see this can get a little bit
tedious but we'll we'll keep our spirits
up so minus 2 times minus 2 times 1
times its sub-matrix so that's this guy
right here times the determinant of its
sub-matrix 2 3 0 0 then minus 2 minus 2
times get rid of that row that column 0
3 2 0 0 3 2 0 and then plus 0 plus 0
times 0 2 2 0 0 2 2 0 that's this one
right there
halfway there at least for now and then
we get this next one so we have a plus
three plus three bring out our
parentheses and then we're gonna have
one times its sub I guess call it sub
determinant so one times determinant one
three three zero right you get rid of
this guy's row and column you get this
guy right there and then minus zero
minus zero get rid of this row and
column times zero three two zero zero
three two zero and then you have plus
zero plus zero times its sub determinant
zero one two three zero one two three
three-fourths of the way there one last
term let's hope we haven't made any
careless mistakes minus four times one
times one two three zero right there
one two three zero minus zero times get
rid of those two guys zero two two zero
zero two two zero and then plus two
times zero one two three right plus to
get rid of these guys zero one two three
zero one two three now we've defined our
or we've calculated or we've defined our
determinant of this matrix in terms of
just a bunch of two-by-two matrices so
you hopefully you saw in this example
that the recursion worked out so let's
actually find what this number is equal
to a determinant is always just going to
be a number so let me get a nice vibrant
color this is a zero times I don't kiss
here times anything is going to be zero
zero times anything is going to be zero
zero times anything is going to be zero
zero times anything is going to be zero
just simplifying it these guys are zero
because it's zero times at zero times
this is going to be equal to zero
so what are we left with what are we
left with
we this is going to be equal to one
times this is all we have left here's a
minus two times and what is this
determinants 1 times 0 which is 0 its 0
let me write this this is going to be 1
times 0 0
- 3 times 3 0 - 9 so - 9 this right here
is just minus 9 so minus 2 times minus 9
that's our first thing I'll simplify it
in a second now let's do this term right
here so it's minus 2 times now what's
this determinant 2 times 0 minus 0 times
3 that's 0 minus 0 so this is 0 that guy
became 0 so we can ignore that term this
term right here 0 times 0 which is 0
minus 2 times 3 so it's minus 6 so it's
minus 2 times so this is a minus 6 right
here you have a minus 2 times a minus 6
so that's a plus 12 so I'll just write a
plus 12 here this minus 2 is that minus
2 right there and then we have a plus 3
we have this plus 3 and then this first
term is 1 times 0 which is 0 - make a
parenthesis here 1 times 0 which is 0
minus 3 times 3 which is minus 9 times 1
so it's minus 9 everything else was a 0
or in the homestretch we have a minus of
4 minus 4 let's see this is 1 times 0
which is 0 minus 3 times 2 so minus 6 so
this is minus 6 right here minus 6 this
is 0 and then we have this guy right
here so we have 0 times 3 which is 0
minus 2 times 1 so that's minus 2 that's
minus 2 and then you have a minus 2
times a plus 2 is minus 4 so now we just
have to make sure we do our arithmetic
properly this is 1 times plus 18 so this
is 18 right minus 2 times minus 9 this
right here is minus 24
this right here is minus 27 and then
this right here let's see this is minus
10 right here that is minus 10 minus 4
times minus 10 is plus 40 plus 40 plus
40 and let's see if we can simplify this
a little bit if we simplify this a
little bit I don't want to make a
careless mistake right at the end
so 18-24
18-24 24 minus 18 is 6 so this is going
to be equal to minus 6 right 18 minus 24
is minus 6 and then we do it in green
now what's the difference if we have
minus 27 minus 27 plus 40
that's 13 right it's positive 13 so
minus 6 plus positive 13 is equal to 7
and so we are done after all of that
computation hopefully we haven't made a
careless mistake
the determinant of this character right
here is equal to 7 the determinant is
equal to 7 and so the one useful
takeaway we know that this is invertible
because it has a nonzero determinant
hopefully you found that useful